all right it looks like we are now live
for another one of these fairly new
discussions in a series of talks and
discussions about important things in
political theory and application so a
little bit of backstory I started doing
this about well officially a month ago
but two months ago I did a rather
impromptu chat about protests and
policing and then last month I did
something about the social contract this
month we're talking about free speech
and cancel culture if there is such a
thing and the Harper's letter next next
month I think we're probably going to
talk about the mechanics of shuffling
all these kids off to school since
that's going to be approaching and the
political thing surrounding that so I'm
going to talk for about 20 minutes or so
I'm going to also ask everybody to make
sure that their comments are relative
their comments are relevant not relative
relevant to the topic so this is not an
AMA this is a focused discussion on a
particular set of topics make sure that
you're being civil with everybody as
you're gonna find out I am NOT a free
speech absolutist and I view things like
this as sort of like being on my front
porch and having a discussion rather
than as the ideological construct of the
marketplace of ideas where anything goes
but I'll talk about that a little bit
more later on so the the thing that
we're gonna focus on to begin with is
this Harper's letter and I see from some
of the comments that some people haven't
read the Harper's letter you probably do
want to take a look at that because
that's part of the context of the
discussion so what was the Harper's
letter it's a fairly short piece in
Harper's Weekly which is kind of a you
know top tier opinion magazine that's
been a
for quite a while and it was signed on
by a lot of people who have quite a bit
of you could say social capital or clout
or whatever you want to call it ranging
from you know Noam Chomsky to people in
the IDW like Barry Weiss to you know all
sorts of people in between I'm not gonna
rehearse try to pick out who is more
important and they're really worried
about a big problem
that's that's looming in front of us
right now so I'm gonna read you some
excerpts from it and I'm gonna say that
there's there's three main things for
the excerpts that I'm reading one is the
big and present problem they're calling
out the left the second now that isn't a
beer that's a what is that seltzer water
get my mind on other things right now so
we're gonna talk about the big and
recent problem that they're talking
about then they get down to specifics
and this is where things start to go off
kilter for them I would say more than
then other places and then they're
speaking for all the rest of us they're
they're doing something that's almost
like a public service so the big and
recent problem here's here's their their
stuff verbatim this needed reckoning
reckoning about you know policing power
that sort of stuff
racism has intensified a new set of
moral attitudes and political
commitments that tend to weaken our
norms of open debate and tolerances of
toleration of differences in favor of
ideological conformity as we applaud the
first development that is the needed
reckoning we also raise our voices
against the second when they say
resistance must not be allowed to harden
into its own brand of dogma and coercion
which right-wing demagogues are already
exploiting the Democratic inclusion we
want can be achieved only if we speak
out against the intolerant climate that
is set in on all sides the free exchange
of information and ideas the lifeblood
of a liberal society is daily becoming
more constricted well we have come to
expect this on the radical rights and
Sharia sness is also spreading more
widely in our culture and in tolerance
of opposing views of vogue for public
shaming and ostracism and the tendency
to dissolve complex policy issues
blinding moral certainty we have hold
the value of robust and even caustic
counter speech from all quarters so
they're doing a couple things there one
is you know saying that they're they're
not quite free speech absolutist but
there's close to it as you can possibly
get and there's a big big problem that's
happening right now so here's some of
the specifics editors are being fired
for running controversial pieces books
are withdrawn for alleged you know
authenticity journalists are barred from
writing on certain topics professors are
investigated for quoting wokes works of
literature in a class a researcher is
fired for circulating a peer-reviewed
academic study and the heads of
organizations are out stood for what are
sometimes just clumsy mistakes so we're
gonna look at some of that in a bit and
then here's the speaking for the rest of
us part remember that the signatories of
this letter are the the people who are
considered important enough to sign on
to it as one of the commentators wrote
later on the restriction of debate
whether by a repressive government or an
intolerant Society invariably hurts
those who lack power and makes everyone
less capable of democratic participation
the way to defeat bad ideas is by
exposure argument and persuasion not
trying to silence or wish them away so
there's a lot to be said about this and
we're gonna come back to what what you
know some of my views are on it and some
of the other commentators views are on
it but you know a few of you are
pointing out it is quite flowery
rhetoric and it is and it is rhetoric
for the most part so when we think about
this issue of freedom of speech right
it's something that is taken as a right
and that tends to be the the main term
that dominates the discourse on it's
taken as a right by many and if we're
looking at this in a precise manner
really the biggest danger is is not you
know society its government right that's
the traditional way of looking at it if
we want to talk about you know the First
Amendment the First Amendment doesn't
have anything to say about your
workplace or you know school or stuff
like that it's specifically about
government interference with speech and
you know it's been given precision in
the
States by the Supreme Court in ways that
narrowed it considerably also in ways
that that expanded it considerably where
you know for example spending money on
political campaigns by corporations is
considered free speech and citizens
united it also has a looser sense and I
think this is what they have in mind and
this is what most of us have in mind
so going just to the First Amendment is
kind of a non-starter most of the time
unless you plan to like argue a
constitutional case what do we have in
mind most of the time sort of like
getting to say what you want without
encountering any sort of repercussions
or reprisals or censorship or shutdowns
or things like that and this you know
little kids can operate with this
concept and they say you know I'm on the
playground and I call you know Timmy an
idiot that's my freedom of speech okay
then maybe there's something to that but
if that's all there is just getting to
blather on about whatever you want I'm
not sure that it's actually that that
important of a issue usually it gets
framed in terms of all sorts of
interesting ideological constructs you
know for example the marketplace of
ideas that people want to invoke all the
time and we're gonna look at that in
just a bit
or totally open fields for a discussion
or these you know interminable
conversations that go on and on and on
and those you know they may have some
utility but they also I think obscure
what's what's going on a lot of the time
and you can frame it in a couple
different ways now somebody's you know
asking about mill in here of course
we're going to talk about John Stuart
Mill a bit and right now is where we're
going to do it one way that you can
frame free speech is in terms of rights
everybody has a certain set of rights
those rights and where other people's
rights begin and where those those lines
are is kind of hazy a lot of the time
and interestingly enough people use
their free speech to argue about why
their free speech matters than other
people's free speech or other people's
rights for example to safety or privacy
or things like that
John Stuart Mill one of the things
that's really cool about
liberté as he says okay rights that's
fine I'm not gonna argue on that basis I
me utilitarian I'm interested in what
works out better for people in general
and so the arguments that I'm gonna
provide are not going to be based on my
rights you know your rights or stuff
like that or some sort of de ontological
basis you could say instead we're gonna
see whether it's actually to the general
benefit to allow as much free speech as
possible free speech in in not in a
complete sense because Mill certainly
does acknowledge the legitimacy of
telling somebody I don't have a
conversation with you because you're a
jerk that's not impinge upon somebody's
free speech but he's interested in
whether it conduces to the general
benefit to actually have something like
an open forum if you're not in a
marketplace of ideas and the other thing
that I'll say that really predominates
in the free speech discussions of today
is what we might call a toughness or
anti snowflake motif right everybody
should be willing to hear everybody else
out all the time even if it's very
noxious or hateful or done in bad faith
and that may be something that we would
want to discuss down down the line I
think we should be really clear that a
lot of speech whether we think of it in
terms of writing or discussion or you
know political contributions here in the
United States is actually not
particularly edifying or OnPoint or good
or anything like that it's it's you know
generally the person who's saying
something unless they're just being a
jerk or a troll or you know anything
along those lines are trying to own the
libs or own the Conservatives or any
sort of noxious antagonistic thing like
that generally they think what they had
to say is good but nobody else has to
actually buy into that and a lot of
people you know say quite quite foolish
and stupid things and the question is
should we you know should we be open to
that now I want to talk a little bit
about this marketplace of ideas thing we
use this as a metaphor quite frequently
it's not a very good metaphor when you
think about it the idea is you know
there's two basic ideas to it one is
that in a market place according to
ideal theory about the way market places
work which is not what we actually see
in practice the best ideas should you
know get market traction and the worse
idea should should go away because
customers won't buy them you know
sometimes it happens sometimes it
doesn't the other is that we already
have the greatest variety of offerings
sort of like when you walk into the
supermarket it's not enough to have
three flavors of spaghetti sauce you
need to have 26 or 108 or whatever the
market will bear right
so don't you know that's that's part of
what's behind this idea I think that the
marketplace of ideas notion ignores the
way real market places work and the way
they intersect with the way in which we
express things if I walk into an actual
place of business and just start
spouting stuff I'll get kicked out most
likely and if I try to appeal to free
speech or say I have to be there to do
it I'll probably not get a good hearing
from those those people and there's all
sorts of other ways in which you know
economic pressures come to bear on
people I know there's a lot of people
who keep things under wraps because of
their jobs and it's not just you know
because of the predominance of leftists
in the university are you actually going
to do is spend a little bit of time in
the university to realize that leftist
don't actually run most universities and
and similarly you know expressing
extreme views within most corporate
workplaces will get you in trouble
unless the corporation heads you know
agree with your political ideas another
big problem with the marketplace of
ideas notion is that you know a lot of
speech drowns out other speech and
whoever does have the biggest megaphone
or the best way of articulating things
to many many people is probably going to
benefit more from the marketplace than
other people
great
example of this that just came up today
Lady Antebellum the band decided to
change its name to Lady a there's
already an african-american artist who's
been recording under that name for years
and years and years she found that in
all of the streaming services Lady
Antebellum now Lady a pushed her totally
out so you know the marketplace might
not be the best model for things and we
do have to ask ourselves if we want
employees well what's actually being
bought and sold what are the
transactions so it's not a really great
metaphor another thing that we needed
talk about is is censorship people throw
this term around rather loosely strictly
speaking censorship is when you're not
allowing something to be set you know or
when you're you're punishing it
afterwards and it's typically on the
part of the government or our you know
social institutions we don't really talk
about individuals censoring each other
unless there's some sort of power
relationship between them and we can
talk about a boss censoring an employee
in some sense but most of the time that
people use this word censorship but it's
not really censorship as as such the
concept has been extended however in a
number of different ways so we can talk
about people you know referring to
censorship within institutions like a
company you know oh I can't say what I
want within the workplace and there you
know there are cases of you know if you
if you try to unionize a lot of
workplaces you'll probably face some
reprisals and that's use of your your
communication faculties to do that are
they censoring you it really kind of
depends news opinion sources you know
they don't allow every single story to
be published are they are they
automatically censoring because of that
schools you know colleges universities
religious organizations clubs those are
all places where people complain about
censorship they even complain about it
within families or groups of friends you
know I remember as a kid talking about
you know my mom not letting me have
freedom of speech and actually my kids
have done that with me as well when I
say we're done with this Congress
I've heard you we're not going to
discuss this any further right I don't
think that we should really call that
censorship and then we can also talk
about social media platforms themselves
now this is where it gets really
interesting these days right and this is
where the canceled culture starts to fit
in with it we we all we do need to
distinguish between what platforms
themselves do and we're gonna talk about
that a bit more in a bit and what groups
individuals who are not you know the
ones who run the platform but are using
the platform do so you know for example
when Twitter you know signals that that
some of trumps tweets are dubious it's
not quite censoring even though they
called it that it's it's doing something
else because you can still see the tweet
right if they actually kick somebody off
of a platform altogether okay I think
you can talk then about something like
censoring and we can have some debate
about whether deep platforming it really
is censoring or not given that the same
information can easily be placed in
other other venues I don't think that
what individuals are doing and blocking
and calling out or stuff like that is
actually censoring on social media
platforms but we'll get to that in a bit
now this leads into another
consideration so if I have free speech
and you have free speech and I say
things that you don't like or things
that are actually hurtful and hateful to
you you can use your free speech to
respond to me and if I'm going to cry
about it afterwards and say oh I
shouldn't face little sort of reprisals
on being a bit hypocritical aren't I
this is an issue that goes all the way
back to Plato's Cratylus if you you know
if you haven't read that dialogue most
people don't it's well worth reading
it's all about language and one of the
things that Plato says in there that's
really interesting you brings the
conversation around to legislation laws
our language you know writing somebody
up and firing them after three write-ups
that is a use of language all of these
things fall within the purview not just
of action but of language of speech
communication and so the question that
we often want to ask is well where it is
something that's a speech act slide into
being an act act right so you know we
might think about calling for somebody
to be fired is that actually a an action
or is that more Act of communication if
I have the you know the capacity to
offend you then you have the capacity to
claim that I should be you know censured
in some sort of way
notice I said censure did not send sword
all right which are two different things
and here's where we get to another thing
that's quite interesting to think about
from the utilitarian perspective and
this is where mill is coming from in
part so Jeremy Bentham the founder of
utilitarianism enunciated something that
I think is quite common across the board
in in 17th and 18th century and also
19th century ideas about the way that
communication and action ought to work
in terms of politics and culture so
there's something that develops that we
can call the public sphere or publicity
and this is where public opinion becomes
important and before the internet of
course back in that time it's
communicated through pamphlets and books
and letters and you know discussions and
coffee houses or taverns or things like
that as well as remonstrances with the
government and there's this
understanding on Bentham's part that
sanctions get imposed on people for
engaging in what he calls anti-social
behavior or which can also sometimes
just be you know selfish behavior and
among the sanctions that he talks about
are you know the physical sanction and
then he talks about the political
sanction the political sanction is when
the government actually uses force
against you and you know say confiscates
your goods or something like that then
he also talks about the social and he
changes is views on this or the language
if
one text to the the the next over the
course of his career calls it the social
or the moral sanction and this is when
you know because you're a jerk your
neighbors don't want to talk to you
you're being sanctioned and you're being
sanctioned for being you know kind of a
jerk to other people and you know
Bentham sees a fundamental difference
between this and so did most people in
the eighteenth century if I choose not
to engage with you economically if I
choose to tell other people not to
engage with you economically provided
I'm not doing it just to be a malicious
jerk there's a certain legitimacy to
that in you know all of this this
thought and and mill similarly use
things that way as well it's not just a
free-for-all of speech there are
consequences to it
so if you're going to demand free speech
for yourself then you also have to
Accord free speech to others and that
free speech others might be offensive to
you or it might in fact impinge upon
your business interests or affect
whether you get into a particular
college or university or not or hold the
job or things like that and I think that
a lot of what's missing in these free
speech discussions is you know basic
principle of prudence
in thinking about one's own position and
I'm going to be very crude here when I
was a kid I was you know I I I got an
all sorts of trouble and I remember when
I was a ward of the court and I was in
this place called shelter care because
of the the amount of trouble that I'd
gotten into I was being a jerk to some
of the staff and they didn't want to
talk to me and then after I I was you
know upset about this I was like how can
we talk to that guy you don't talk to me
and I remember one of them got in my
face and he said I'm gonna make it super
clear to you Greg act like an [ __ ]
get treated like an [ __ ] and I think
that should be like the model for a lot
of exercises of free speech if you go on
the attack
don't be surprised that other people go
on the attack against you you know and
you know there's probably need to be
some limits to that and we'll talk about
that more in the discussion but I think
that
something that's missing a lot we also
live in a time when reproduction and
reframing of these let's call them
agonistic interactions they're super
easy to do in social media and then you
can cut you can like do a screen shot
you can do copy and pasting and so we
live in a different time you know in the
past if you said something off-color at
a barbecue right and it was all your
friends around maybe nobody was actually
paying that much attention to it now you
could be recorded at any time and so a
lot of people feel very worried about
that like oh what's what's gonna come
out of my mouth you know what's gonna
happen and this is there's a legitimate
concern here when we look at you know
the transformation of sort of normative
lines but we could have been wrong in
the past and maybe there's a lot of
stuff that we let fly that actually
looking back on it was quite wrong to do
I think that what's what's going on
right now is people are actually looking
for accountability in terms of what
people what other people are saying and
so this is where you know I'm gonna
bring in my own views it looks like I am
gonna go over a little bit I'll probably
wrap this up around the half an hour
time so my own views about social media
because this has been something that a
lot of people have brought up here and
there I think we have a big issue that
we should talk about another time about
platforms what are they you know what is
Twitter what is Facebook are they just
private companies are they media
aggregators or publishers are they
public utilities I'm gonna put that
aside for right now what I'm going to
say that is this banning blocking people
calling them out on stuff fact-checking
them that is not actually censoring
people because they can go elsewhere and
they they have a platform elsewhere
there's a lot of different possibilities
it's not like there's only one social
media place in town I think a lot of
people are worried about their economic
basis right particularly those who are
earning a ton of money from say YouTube
or ad revenue or things like that but
here's my view I'm going to put aside
sort of the public issue
and talk about you know groups pages
YouTube channels interactions like that
I think that one's own spaces in public
and social media are exactly that one
zone spot and it's up to moderators or
content producers to do whatever they
want with it so if I'm posting on you
know the classic metal group something
like hey metal sucks I can expect to
encounter a lot of resistance and I can
expect perhaps if I'm going to be a jerk
to get kicked out of that group and
banned and I think that's perfectly fine
there's nothing wrong with that and you
could make an argument that it's better
to engage the jerks or the misguided or
something like that or that people like
that have a right to be heard or express
themselves and my answer to that so
those are two separate issues the first
one is an issue of time and merit
you know we each get 24 hours a day I
probably filled anywhere and I'm almost
a small fish in the social media pond
if you think about Twitter YouTube and
Facebook I probably respond to at least
30 people a day in one way or another
and the question is well who actually
merits a conversation and who doesn't
now you know somebody does some random
person popping in because they were
upset about how I tweaked their
ideological you know heartstrings or
something like that I don't actually
have an obligation to engage with them
or enlighten them or anything like that
as a matter of fact I I created some
videos where I just post them and I'm
like hey you can go google that or you
know here's here's my standard response
to that right let's see Barnard says
you're a middle sized fish I'd say no
I'm actually a small fish when it comes
to like say most of these things but the
other thing about giving everybody a
space there's no obligation for me to
give anybody a space on my channel or in
my Twitter feed or on my Facebook page
because there's a million other ones
that they can go to it's not like I
control a scarce resource that
you know I'm doling out you know to only
to my cronies or something like that and
I think that we should look at these
spaces as being something like
somebody's front porch or their back
yard you get to be there if you're not a
jerk if they want to kick you out they
kick you out
so the exceptions and I do think there
could be some exceptions would be people
who create forums that are created for
the purpose of totally open discussion
where they declare that to be the
purpose now they would be hypocritical
if you're not doing that let's move on
to canceled culture so canceling what
would actually is canceling there's a
variety of different forms I'm gonna
kind of skip over this economic you know
we can talk about firing people
blackballing them not buying products
destroying products like when
conservatives were burning up their Nike
stuff you know socially not inviting
people to things ostracizing them in
terms of media and not watching a
person's products or calling for a show
to be ended or somebody be kicked off a
show or you know like gotten you know
gotten out of media products like we
people did with Kevin Spacey social
media publishing we can talk about the
platforming people piling on them daxing
intellectually we can say you know maybe
cancel culture extends to not taking
people seriously saying this person's an
idiot don't listen to them right now
canceling is a is really a broader set
of topics that are all connected
together I think and and I really think
that cancel culture is not something and
there's you know people have talked
about pearl clutching when it comes to
conservatives recently talking about
canceled culture and these mostly
liberals and leftists talking about
canceled culture in the harper's letter
and I think that's actually quite data
pearl clutching is when you're you're
claiming that something is a big problem
right now and it's it's actually it's
been around for a long time and so
there's a few things I wanted to read
from some of the the suggested
recommended readings so here's Michael
Hobbs he said for decades American Amer
Media was controlled by a tiny number of
gatekeepers count up all the top editors
of all the national news outlets and the
pre-internet era you would have gotten a
shockingly small number if they if that
tiny group of editors decided an opinion
was not worthy of being heard it wasn't
and that's the case in so many
institutions not just back then but
today now there was a lot of canceling
going on back then all you had to do is
say the wrong thing and it gets to one
of those people or be the wrong kind of
person and you're never gonna get
published right and so the Internet has
really opened things up for us
zài Jelani wrote in their attempts to
remedy the most pernicious aspects of
cancel culture critics of mostly
concentrating and advocating less
punitive social norms that's good as it
goes so she's you know say saying there
is cancel culture but here's here's one
of the big problems
maybe the employment aspect wouldn't be
such a big problem if we didn't have all
this crazy at-will employment right if
we were more like the Europeans who you
actually have to have a good reason to
fire somebody not just they happen it
said something bad on social media it's
worth considering myself I'd really like
to see some consistency from those
complaining about cancel culture and I
don't demand perfect consistency but at
least something's showing that they're
communicating in relatively good faith
so if you're complaining about cancel
culture and you're on the left and
you're only targeting conservatives I
think that's kind of [ __ ] and i
likewise think that from people on the
right that it's kind of [ __ ] you
know I also think that relying on just a
few anecdotes which is what the letter
did is really problematic great example
of this is you know anybody who's
actually spent much time in academic
institutions and didn't go and as a pure
ideologue knows that there's not a lot
of indoctrination taking place because
it's hard as hell they indoctrinate the
students just to read the friggin texts
right and to do the work let alone and
doctrine ate them into some overarching
Marxist conspiracy that's all just that
that's all just you know
fever dream nonsense dreamt up by
conservatives who get into that sort of
thing
there are a few places where you can
find something remotely like that but I
can tell you and I teach at quite a few
places around here it ain't like that so
I think we have to be really quite you
know I think we have to be quite quite
careful about those sorts of things and
you know here's one of my other
suggestions I'm actually going to stop
so I can say I'm not going to talk about
all the different things I wanted to get
to because I want to answer some of
these questions I think that free speech
you know you can regard it as a right if
you want to and you can make that the
focus of your discourse I think that's
working about rights without
responsibilities has been one of the big
problems here in America and I think
that it you know we've we've seen that
in other places in the world as well
it's one thing to insist that other
people give you a hearing I think that
introduces another requirement that you
give a good faith hearing to other
people as well and that you respect some
boundaries and that you don't you know
why or distort or and so there's what we
might call communicational or do you
know epistemological norms built into
free speech and I think a lot of people
will disagree with me on that but that's
that's that's my view on it so there's
lots and lots of people who have written
things in here I'm gonna scroll up to
the top and see what people have to say
remember keep your comments relevant and
civil to other people in here Callum
says ironic that those complaining about
canceled culture costing people their
jobs like milo shapiro jordan peterson
have literally built careers from it i
think some have Shapiro's a particularly
you know a good example of that because
he sent internet mobs after people on
different occasions and i think that we
should be wearing i think that the
higher up the person is the more wary we
should be about their complaints about
canceled culture I'm not saying that
that we need to romanticize the you know
the little person at the bottom but I
think there's a lot more [ __ ] about
canceled culture the further up that we
go all right let's see read 50 - what
are your thoughts on removing statues of
people like Thomas Jefferson with his
mixed legacy personally I don't actually
have much problem with with removing
statues I think the whole like we learn
history from them idea is as stupid and
[ __ ] and you know that anybody who
actually has to look at a statue instead
of reading a book has got some serious
issues I mean we're not back in the
Middle Ages where the cathedrals were
Bibles and stone you know we have a
literate society and you know I mean if
you if you can't see a picture of Thomas
Jefferson in your hometown you can go on
the internet and find them easily I
think that you know we need to when
we're talking about statues the ones
that are being there's really like two
classes of statues being pulled down
there's a people who are clearly
egregious bad people you know and and
we're allowed to be glorified for one
reason or another and they've been
pulling those statues down and then
there's one where it's more mixed cases
right personally when I pull a statue of
Thomas Jefferson down no but do I care
if Thomas Jefferson statue gets pulled
down not much I think there's bigger
fish to fry
but you know you and you can hear what I
have to say about Confederate statues on
the interview that I did with Tom
Ritchie a long time about that mark says
I feel that the Harper's letter was too
vague to be of any use
I think it's it can be used
ideologically and and the reason piece
that I suggested is a great example of
that where and there was another one as
well in the for reactions or their son
can't you know the this this canceled
culture is going after the letter now so
I think I think it can be abuse
ideologically Jacobs
as I read and like the open letter I
think cancel culture is a major danger
have you experienced observed cancel
culture in your own academic career yeah
I mean I actually had a person I was
working with on a translation project
who tried to get me fired and luckily
the Dean told that person to go you know
basically take a long walk off a short
pier and I've seen you know people
bringing up all sorts of frivolous
[ __ ] complaints and then sometimes
some real legitimate complaints the the
bad thing is that it's hard to get
legitimate complaints taken seriously
within academia you know we have these
egregious sexual harassers who were you
know people you know knew about them and
they tell female graduate students avoid
them times pulga for example john searle
and the university would cover for them
I don't think I don't think that you
know so with a few exceptions I don't
think that canceled culture is the big
problem that people are making it out to
be I mean I don't see an awful lot of
evidence of it working the way that the
people concerned about it are are saying
so a lot of that is sort of imagination
on their part I think bradford studying
mine comp is not a crime for example no
it's it's not a crime as a matter of
fact I think that it's worth actually
looking at mine comp so you can see the
sort of lines of reasoning that people
like Hitler are spouting and then you
can identify them with people on the
right today and say holy crap this is
like straight out of the playbook
you know I also think that you should
read Charles Marat you know instead of
just you know talking about Steve ban
and what he has to say
he's basically a replication of this guy
who started accion France says at a
proto fascist organization that came out
of the Dreyfus Affair in France I think
we should read up this stuff I'm not
saying that we should lock up the books
or anything but that's not what canceled
culture free speech is really centering
around now is it alright um let's see
so here's another interest thing about
Mayan comp right I have a copy of mine
comp I've read from but I definitely
don't display it prominently on my
bookshelf okay that's that's a
significant point now why not display it
prominently on your bookshelf because
the very act of displaying it would
probably lead people to think that you
not only are studying it but that you
think that it's it's a good work right
and that you're endorsing it in some way
this is why in Twitter a lot of people
put in their Twitter profile retweets or
not endorsements because they're I
suppose there's a natural human tendency
to think that people who are bringing
something up are bringing it up because
they like it and so I want to say two
points about that because that's that's
really quite interesting and so these
are these are a bit of a digression one
is that on a personal level I often run
into people who because I cover such a
wide range of thinkers and I do so
sympathetically where they will say oh
man I thought you were Nietzschean
because you present on Nietzsche or I
thought you were uh you know a Hegelian
or I thought you're a stoic or stuff
like that and I suppose there's this
natural human tendency to think well if
you're presenting about it it must be
because you think it's important and
it's worth worth engaging with and I
think for a lot of people that is the
way that they do things they only talk
about stuff that they think is good
unless they want to talk condemning Lee
about stuff that they think is bad right
but that's not the way it works in
academia and that's not the way it works
in sort of higher level opinion
discussions that fit into what we were
calling earlier the public sphere and
that's not necessarily the way it works
even on social media so that's that's
that's one aspect of that the other
aspect about the endorsing so you could
say that like putting a photograph of
your bookshelf is in a way a
communicative act right communication
doesn't just have to do with what comes
out of your mouth or what you type you
know tippy-tap type on your typewriter
keyboard or what you say in a video
which I guess is coming out of your
mouth - but what you surround yourself
with and this is where we have to be
quite careful in the judgments that we
we make about about people you know
there is guilt by association a lot of
the time all right let's see here here's
that here's a question that I think is a
good one philosophy and critical
thinking do I think that contrasting the
different kinds of freedom such as
positive and negative freedom is helpful
in discussing freedom of speech so let's
let's talk about what the distinction
between positive and negative freedom
amounts to and one of the classical
places to go to this Isaiah Berlin two
concepts of Liberty right that's what I
need to do some core concepts about
because people ask me about it all the
time and I should start teaching it in
my classes so negative freedom is
freedom from and positive freedom is
freedom for that's the slogan that
usually goes with that negative freedom
is essentially saying other people
should not prevent you from something so
freedom of speech is usually viewed as a
negative freedom right
you shouldn't have excuse me
you shouldn't have anybody else
restricting what it is that you say
positive freedom does fit in with speech
though positive freedom is the capacity
to develop towards something good for
yourself or say a set of relationships
or something else you know it's often
associated with what we call
perfectionism in ethics meaning this
this notion that there is like a
definite human nature to be realized and
we ought to do what we can to try to
realize or perfect it so I'm saying for
example that human beings are social
creatures and we ought to live in
harmony with each other that's a
positive ideal and we could say that
that you know freedom of speech can
certainly conduce to that but I don't
think that freedom of speech per se
pertains to that if that if that helps
you alright let's see here
lotta back-and-forth stuff literally
Dazza and here's an interesting question
this is actually a really good one can
we consider how good is an idea based on
the way it is presented so that can that
can mean a lot of different things but I
think there's something important there
you know it again Mills on Liberty which
is sort of a locust classic us right for
for freedom of speech discussions he
talks about limiting intemperate
discussions and there were a lot of
people who are like listen I'm cool with
hearing stuff that I think is wrong or I
don't want to hear but I don't want it
set at me like in such a uncivil way in
a threatening way or angry way or stuff
like that right I don't wanna be name
called and mill actually comes down on
the side of saying well it's really hard
to police that I'm not gonna you know
say that that we should start
restricting things based on how they're
expressed I don't agree with them on
that I think that there's many different
ways to get your point across you know
if you think about John Lennon's quip
you know if you go around carrying
pictures of Chairman Mao you're not
going to make it with anyone anyhow okay
that's that's right if you want to be in
your face and be a jerk to people don't
be surprised if they're a jerk to you
and if you are you know culturally
insensitive because you didn't take the
time to actually learn about other
people or you're coming from a very
privileged position and other people
call you out on it I don't have much
sympathy for that quite frankly I know I
even I've certainly had my share of
getting that sort of stuff in my face
over the years from being a kid on but
yeah
way in which we express things I think
does matter and you know this so
remember how I was talking about rights
responsibilities you know when you when
the whole stress is on my right to say
what I want and there's no like thinking
about is there is there a better way for
me to express this do I have a
responsibility to actually engage my
interlocutors in good faith that's when
we run into a lot of problems so that's
a great question all right here's a good
good point from eight and rights or one
thing the ability and degree to which
you can use them is another yeah and
this is where we get to you know a lot
of these free speech things you know not
everybody has the same same platform for
free speech do they you know when I was
saying I'm kind of a little fish and if
you look at you know like the scale of
people on YouTube or Twitter there's
there's a cool thing you can look up
called philosophers on Twitter I'm down
there and the like a hundred and thirty
s you know there are some people where
if they say something tens of thousands
of people are seeing it in their stream
right away there's there's pages in
Facebook and the you know even for just
philosophy stuff where you have access
to fifty thousand people right or
YouTube channels where there are
millions of subscribers rather than I'm
not even at a hundred thousand yet
and I'm you know from the perspective of
a lot of my viewers and stuff I'm you
know kind of up there but that's because
they don't see how many other layers
there are as well we don't all have
access to the same platforms and a lot
of the locking down of free speech
happens at the expense of people or
closer to the bottom than people who are
closer to the top I mean the people who
are closer to the top can usually find
another venue to [ __ ] about how they've
been censored can't they but unless the
unless the ordinary persons experience
somehow fits
to some left-wing or right-wing or some
other narrative usually nobody else pays
attention to them right I mean you know
there there are some exceptions to that
but I think that's that's a really
important point um let's see here here's
a good one from Colin sharp how do we
preserve the right to speech in a
meaningful democracy when some voices
are privileged more than the others
megaphone sighs being marginalized etc
so that's that's time you know thought I
was just talking about
but there's there it's asking about what
do we do so one thing we could do if
we're in platforms that allow us to do
this is to amplify the speech of those
who don't have big accounts you know we
we use our slightly larger account to
amplify them and we don't maybe
necessarily amplify what Nike has to say
or what you know this celebrity has to
say you know way to do that on Twitter
is you screenshot the person's tweet and
instead of actually like retweeting
their tweet you you tweet the screenshot
of it with your commentary above
I think there's ways to do this one of
the things I really like about Twitter
is that I can you know because of the
way I follow people in the way that I
unfollow and block and stuff like that I
have I get a really good feed with a lot
of cool people who have interesting
things to say that are not necessarily
within you know the normal spectrum of
the mainstream and they're not like
movers and shakers in the traditional or
social media and I wind up benefiting as
as a result of that so I don't know that
that's a much bigger discussion to be
had let's see here
Aidan if you spout blind leftist stuff
in a university tutorial people call you
out on it sits so blown up the
universities are blind leftist bubbles
yeah that that's that's exactly the case
if you go into I mean if you go into
most professors classes and you just you
know make a bunch of talking points the
professors are not usually too happy
about that professors are not usually
people who are just ideologue and like I
said I'll got to be my way because you
know academia doesn't doesn't attract
that sort I mean there are some like
that of course I mean where you find a
lot more conformity of thought is in the
corporate world you know and I you know
have being somebody who's moved in a lot
of different sectors that's where I see
way more groupthink is in a lot of
corporations than in academic
institutions let's see John wants to
claim they are overwhelmingly cultural
leftist nonetheless especially those in
administrative roles though that some
false administrators are usually the
ones who are union-busting who are you
know trying to cut cost as much as
possible they may have a thin veneer of
progressive clauses to them but no with
again very rare exceptions that's not
the case
all right let's see here gutter grown
says I'm with Charles L Lawrence the
third on his view that some hate speech
is fighting words based on the normative
valuation for example the n-word you
know I'd go along with that I think
there to begin with if one wants to use
hateful epithets
there's usually a good point where
somebody should pause and say is this
really what I want to say what are my
motives for doing this and I think if
people are honest with themselves and
they don't lie to themselves about you
know their free speech or how important
it is to like you know they get to use
these words or something like that I
think in a lot of cases people would be
like oh yeah this is gonna hurt somebody
else and whether it hurts their feelings
or is a microaggression or you know
calls back to trauma I don't think it
really matters you know if you're if
you're deliberately saying things that
you know are gonna be hurtful and
hateful to people and you don't have
some good reason for doing so you're an
[ __ ]
that's all there is to it and if you do
it in certain areas
I mean imagine going into some parts of
Milwaukee which is one of the most
segregated city large cities in the
United States and you know walking down
the street and deliberately using the
n-word and then somebody coming up to
you and clocking you you know I would
say okay so they probably shouldn't have
hit you but you are an idiot
and you should have seen that coming as
well you know and I think there's a lot
of things like that you know and it's
some people say oh we're being too
sensitive you know it was okay to use
this word before or that in that group
uses that word themselves and and so
much of this to me is is like get over
it we have an English language that is
one of the richest and vocabulary in the
world you know in part because we took
loan words from so many you can
communicate what you need to communicate
without that I mean it's sort of like
there's a different issue the use of
profanity right the f-word or you know
where people are like F and this F and
that you know we joke about and we're
like you know the f-word can be a noun a
verb an adverb an adjective it's so you
know so useful it's useful if you really
don't have anything much to say other
than alababama
you know articulate people can actually
say things in a variety of different
ways you know so you know
that's a little bit off-topic there but
alright
Oh nish nishant says can we speak about
the specifics in the letter is there
something that happened recently that
trigger this letter solo yeah like I
mentioned there's that section where
they are talking about specific cases
right that they want to bring up and so
editors are fired for running
controversial pieces right so the editor
of the New York Times resigned after
bringing Tom cotton in to write this
fever dream of totalitarianism that was
his piece right and a lot of people are
like this is really you know I mean The
Times is slipping I mean now I'm gonna
actually do a little rant here
personally I think the times has been
garbage most of my life it's it's never
been any better than say the Chicago
Tribune or the you know when it was good
the Milwaukee Sentinel you know I think
that a lot of people give way too much
credence to these these top-tier opinion
formers when they're really just you
know replicating elite culture and and
their sentiments and it's a very narrow
group of people who get in there and get
to get to use that megaphone now be that
as it may it was a stupid thing to do
and they you know a lot of people like
we're weighed in and they're like here's
my piece that that The Times didn't
publish and what do you think of that
they published this instead of this so
you know that's one of those cases where
there were a lot of bad editorial
decisions that went into it
books are withdrawn for alleged you know
authenticity I wonder if that's Naomi
Wolf spork perhaps journalists are
banned from writing on certain topics
okay that's that's quite true that
happens in a lot of newsrooms that's
been going on for decades if not
centuries professors are investigated
for quoting works of literature and
class okay that's so there is a case
where that actually did happen and you
know there's there's some things where
you probably ought to say before you do
it listen there's
you mentioned distinction here can I do
that the mentioning thing a research is
fired for circulating a peer-reviewed
academic study there's a couple cases
like that out there and heads of
organizations are out stood for what are
sometimes just clumsy mistakes if you're
a head of an organization you don't get
to make dumb mistakes you're you know if
you are liable to make dumb mistakes you
don't have a Twitter right you don't
have a social media presence because
you're a head of an organization so you
know that's that's my views on that but
again when you when you take little bits
of anecdotes and put them together into
a great constellation you ever look at
the night sky and look at constellations
you're like okay I can see Orion there I
sure as hell can't see a club and hair
on his head and stuff like that that's
what a narrative is compared to the
little stars that are the anecdotes so
alright Bradford grrrrrr says I think
asking for someone to be fired for their
speeches vent vengeful more than
correcting so that's a that's a good
topic to explore it really depends on
what they're getting fired from and what
the conditions are so for example
telling police departments that this
this person right here has white power
tattoos on them and beats their wife and
did these things off-duty they should
not be on the police force I don't see
any problem with that as a matter of
fact if we want to resolve some of the
problems of policing we need to get rid
of probably about a third to half of the
people that are on police forces right
now because we have a lot of bad apples
and then maybe they can get retrained
and rehired later you know there have to
be like blackballed for it forever but
there are a lot of people who are
totally unfit to be given Authority and
weapons and stuff like that
likewise CEOs of corporations hey if
you're the CEO the buck stops with you
if you say something stupid on social
media and people call for you to get
fired and the board fires you tough [ __ ]
you know that should be that's where
at-will employment ought to
be the higher you go up the more at-will
it ought to be I think if you're you
know the electrician who is cracking his
knuckles and somebody thinks it's a
white power sign okay that's a real
problem and there's a petition to get
the guy rehired right in that case and
he probably will be rehired
if somebody's mean to you at Walmart
because they're having a bad day and
they're the cashier maybe you actually
are the Karen regardless of whether
you're male female you know or whatever
race you happen to be when you complain
to the manager and want to get them
fired right that that's that's different
so I don't think that we can say across
the board that asking for someone to be
fired for their speech is is more
vengeful than than correcting I think in
a lot of cases people do in fact learn
by losing their jobs and if we think
about a lot of the jobs that people are
doing where they can move from one to
the next again we'll talk about police
right there a lot of the problem cops
out there have been fired from multiple
departments and then rehired by the one
next you know down the road and we can
think of many other things like that as
well unfortunately in the professions
losing your job it really depends on
what your circumstances are there's a
lot of people who are gonna have no
problem going out and getting another
job or they're gonna be on all sorts of
talk shows and earning that money and
getting a book deal out of being you
know discriminated against for their
their firing so I think we have to be
very we have to be case by case almost
with with it this sort of thing all
right Richard Simpson says in these
times because things are so polarizing
and volatile better just not to speak
about politics at work it can destroy
relationships and cohesiveness so there
is something to that and I do know
people who keep their their politics
under wrap at work and you know when it
comes down to me there are situations in
which I think it's appropriate to bring
up your politics and other situations in
which it's irrelevant or or unproductive
to bring it up right and this is where
exercising prudence comes in and again
free speech
understood not just as a right but as a
sense of you know responsibility as well
the people who think that they ought to
be able to spout whatever they want
whenever they want there's a real sense
of entitlement going along with that now
does that mean that in every situation
we ought to like in the old days we said
what are what don't you discuss with the
dinner table
it was always sex religion money or
politics right you pick three out of
that I don't think we have to go that
far but we probably should be a bit more
circumspect about putting everything out
there and there's a lot of people who
say well but I feel so strongly about
this well okay that's you can feel
strongly about whatever you want that
can be that the nation is going to hell
and we need you know to wear red hats in
order to fix it and have rallies or you
know and have jets flying overhead and
we better salute the flag or it could be
well we need to protest and you know
change the court the composition of
police forces and it could be anything
in between right it could be that
graduate students at Marquette ought to
ought to have a union ought to be given
a lot more protection and benefits than
they currently are which I happen to
believe it could be whatever you want
and maybe there are venues to talk about
that and then there's others where you
you don't have to do that this this you
know this notion that it's all or
nothing it's it's a I know there's a lot
of people who feel that way but again I
want to say prudence or practical wisdom
is really something that we need to have
all right
Bradford being offended as a fad as a
part of life I think that's right yeah
and you know one of the things that I
want to develop by the way this total
digression
so at Milwaukee Institute of Art and
Design I have a lot of latitude in the
classes that I suggest an offer much
more than I do at say Milwaukee Area
Technical Institute Technical College
or at marquette where are they to say
you get these classes one of the classes
I really want to develop is like a class
about how to productively argue and
discuss things with people who you don't
agree with and how to develop at least
kind of a thicker skin or more more
flexible way of dealing with people who
do offend you you know and being able to
tell the people who are going to keep on
offending you because they're really
jerks and they get something out of it
or they're sadists and the people who
cross the line and don't realize it now
are really embarrassed and you can reach
right I think those are important
distinctions linden glad to see here
there's the matter of a mood of
intolerance if not a censorship itself
but everyone has their triggers we don't
have a responsibility to take ridiculous
or noxious ideas seriously yeah I think
there's we can talk about there being
kind of norms when it comes to that not
every idea is worth entertaining and not
every view have offended me claim has
the same weight or merit as every other
one I think and I think we do have to be
careful about sort of ascribing what
would you call it
you know I mean it's the thing that
people who are concerned about identity
politics do fear which does happen
sometimes really like well this person
gets to be offended because they belong
to this group and and they're you know
being offended matters more than anybody
else I think we do have to be careful
about that but I think that there's a
lot of like learning about what what
does offend other people that needs to
go on I'm always super surprised and
people who say something bigoted or you
know ignorant or hurtful and then
they're like well I didn't know that
that bothered people and I'm like how
the hell do you not know that what what
rock have you been living under that you
don't know that
this is gonna offend these people over
here but I guess there's a lot of
ignorance out there so maybe there is
some some value to like you know doing
more you know informational stuff about
you know what not to say and why not to
say it Wyatt
why it's offensive philosophy and
critical thinking it may be an
apocryphal but I think Winston Churchill
said some people's idea of freedom of
speech is that anyone can say what they
want but if anyone says anything back
it's an outrage I think there's a lot of
that going on I think a lot of the
complaints about canceled culture
somebody's not actually being cancelled
but they use it as sort of a prop to
gain sympathy for themselves and to also
to attack back the person who said
something that they don't like oh here's
an interesting question from Jay a
should YouTube even be the public sphere
in the first place is Twitter and amped
public sphere I don't think that we get
to decide those sorts of things in any
sort of rational way and so this is this
is actually a really great question so
going back historically I think there
has always been people who are like
these pamphlets these broad sheets that
are being circulated around they go over
the line they say outrageous things look
at them being hammered and nailed on the
public you know walls or something like
that this is outrageous you know and now
we'd be like I mean you walk it around
places where it says post no bills and
it's covered with stuff and it's not
mostly political stuff it's usually like
this band or this DJ and things like
that we just sort of take it for granted
same thing with so many other things
like when radio came out it was viewed
as such a disruptive social force you
know you read like a Gabrielle Marcello
I'm a big fan of talking about how radio
lends itself to you know totalitarian
society and after a while you're like
okay I see how they did use it in
totalitarian societies I think that the
that that worry has been overblown I
think we're stuck
the public sphere that we get and it
continually develops and Twitter is part
of it man you know Twitter is is really
quite interesting because if you think
about I gotta fix my hair is starting to
pull out of the thing if you think about
like compared to Facebook right Facebook
has more users but who do the the news
an opinion shows on like the cable news
networks who do they go to and who have
they gone to for the last 10 years
Twitter they they feel that Twitter is
somehow more important and so you can
put stuff on there and and your tweets
can get into somebody's opinion program
or you see people posting them in you
know blog posts right or right up since
a newspaper articles so I think we're
kind of stuck with Twitter and I think
we're stuck with YouTube what's
interesting is that there's a lot of
other smaller sometimes rival things
that want to become their own publics
their own public sphere things like gab
was gonna you know replace Twitter and
it doesn't seem like it's managed to do
do that well with that I don't know that
there is any real rival to YouTube I
mean you could say dailymotion but or
Vimeo but those don't really have that
much attraction either so I think I
think we're kind of stuck with those and
we have to theorize about well what what
what happens with Twitter and how should
we think about it um let's see here
guter got the grown says ostracism as a
social control yeah and you know
traditional ostracism means like you're
literally cast out of the city or cast
out of the political community or social
community altogether that's pretty rare
these days usually it's like somebody's
pushed off of this platform and then
they appear somewhere else and they're
not they can always find somebody to
hang out with it's rare to find people
who've been like totally ostracized
Bradford Gerst I tell my daughter the
same thing if you're a jerk people won't
like you and you lose friend I'm sorry
that that you and your daughter are
going through that but it's a part of
the learning process hopefully your
daughter is not as hard-headed as I was
as a kid yeah I think that this is this
is actually part of the maturation
process the part of the process of
turning into a genuine fully developed
human being is often realizing that you
have been a jerk and that you need to
like start fixing both parts of yourself
and that other people enabling you and
telling you that it was okay we're
probably off base and getting something
out of it well this is actually
something where you know the mechanics
of social media work against us outraged
really is something that contributes to
virality and it's too bad you know anger
is one of the best emotions for getting
people to reshare stuff and you know I
don't know how we get away from that
that's more of a a problem than than any
any sort of solution all right Jas can't
any means of communication serve public
propaganda as much as it could serve
enlightenment yeah I don't think that
there's a technology out there that
can't be turned for something bad and
that's that's part of the nature of it's
interesting because tech people always
want to say oh this is going to like
change everything you
it's the the eternal dream of like well
we're going to finally hand the right
thing and nobody can possibly abuse it
that's part of why I'm a virtue ethicist
I think that we need the virtues in
order to be able to have good
communication and not abuse each other
and you know steer ourselves towards the
right way and have real solidarity John
be the Harper's letter is a joke who
cares what any of these elite puppets
think so I mean I I kind of sympathize
with that I don't I don't have a lot of
love for elites I think many of you
probably know and you know part of that
is from seeing how how things work in
terms of like reproduction of the the
position of elites part of it is just
studying social theory of different
sorts I mean I had one of my really
formative experiences and you know some
people can look at this and say oh man
you you were really lucky and privileged
to do this so I'm gonna tell us a real
quick story when I was in elementary
school you know I was a really smart kid
I grew up out in the sticks in a rural
area where we did have a gifted a
talented program and it was one lady who
drove around the entire district and
would meet with us like once a month or
so and and for a lot of my classes they
would just you know like I was good at
math so they in first grade they gave me
a fourth grade math textbook put me over
in the corner and said go do problems
and then for like English they'd send me
the library with one other kid and say
do some sort of project you know we
don't want to see it and so I wasn't
getting that much out of school I really
did like gym and recess and art music
though like the social aspects and
creative aspects of things and so they
wanted to advance me directly into
seventh grade and it was a rough you
know school and I was like man I'm gonna
get beaten up every single day not only
am i a smart kid so that that's already
got a target on my back but I'm gonna be
smaller than everybody else this is not
a good idea and my parents I never
actually told them that but they they
wanted something more challenging for me
so they found a private school
and they found out that there were there
were scholarships that I could apply for
it and I did and I got the scholarships
because I had high test scores and the
place that I went to the students were
almost invariably either smart bring up
the test scores or rich very little
overlap right and there's a cool place
you know like we learned Latin and you
know the soccer coach was a former
Olympian and there all sorts of really
interesting aspects about that place but
man did I get to see how class dynamics
work you know when you go to school and
you're wearing the clothes that your mom
made or you know the cheap jeans and
corduroys that you bought on sale and
everybody else is wearing eyes odds and
and you know polos of making fun of you
for it you get to see what happens when
you do cross country skiing because
that's that's what you can afford and
everybody else has ski tags going down
there other thing so I think part of
that you know part of my distrust of
elites comes from experiences like
seeing what it's like when you're in
places and you're definitely not of the
world but what they used to call the
demi-monde right and and you're right
the Harper's people none of them really
have to worry about being canceled
Rowling is still selling books just fine
even if she never sells another book the
rest of her life so what is that really
big repercussion it's more about their
feelings it's more about them not
getting to say what they want as a
matter of fact I do one of the things I
wanted to get to great example of this
is and here we go so here's here's
something that Nolan said in the
coddling of the elites thousands of low
paid journalists and freelancers and
adjunct professors and grad student
workers and other campus workers have
fought and marched and organized and
sacrificed to unionize they have done so
because many of them did not earn a
living-wage many of them suffered from
racial discrimination or sexual
harassment or other forms of
institutionalized injustice all of them
lack the power to be able to negotiate
fairly on their own behalf those are the
people who actually make up the creative
underclass these are the people who work
in the knowledge industries who are
enable to exercise free speech because
they often do not have the economic or
social or cultural or labor power to do
so
I think that's completely right you know
and this you know I mentioned that
there's this thing about the in the
letter so in the letter it's speaking up
for the rest of us the restriction of
debate whether by repressive government
or an intolerant society invariably
hurts those who lack power it makes
everyone less capable of democratic
participation so that's true but we
didn't need them to tell us that because
we already know that because we're
already experiencing that they're not so
who the hell are they to talk about it
right and they says the way to defeat
bad ideas is by exposure argument and
persuasion not by trying to silence or
wish them away there may be something to
that but yeah we don't need these these
elite people who sign the letter to do
that so alright let's go on a lot of
back-and-forth about the elite puppets
idea
philosophy and critical thinking am i
aware of the D si D platforming Adolf
read due to charges of being a class
reductionist if so what are your
thoughts on it I'm not because I don't
follow the DSA very much and I think if
if they want a deep platform somebody
they certainly can do that I'd have to
look up who Adolf read actually is but
yeah all right mythological maybe you
should read the first two pages of John
Stuart Mill mob justice is the most vile
and dangerous type of violence and
silencing it's kind of funny you'd think
that I wouldn't be familiar with a book
that I've been like reading for thirty
years been teaching for 20 but thanks
for the advice all right uh let's see
here
oh here's Marx met are you familiar with
the concept of emotional labor do I
think that intersects with issues of
free speech and a duty to be informed
yeah not in a simple way there's a lot
of people who enter into a discussion
and then they say something boneheaded
to somebody else who is like actually
living out something and and they're
like it can't be as bad as you say and
then they're like Jesus why don't you
like do your research and then the first
person is like well can you give me a
list of sources you know can you do the
work for me you know I I encounter this
in a more benign way when it comes to
philosophical topics great example of
that that John Stuart Mill you should
read John Stuart Mill come on you know I
could I could give you a whole list of
secondary literature on it and some of
my videos on it but why that why should
I do that work you know and if I
shouldn't do that work a fortiori
why should for example here's something
that that's been coming up an awful lot
why should African American people who
have been you know suffering under you
know systemic racism in terms not just
of policing but education housing
finance you know down the line we can
talk about this why the hell should they
have to do the work of educating other
people who come into the discussion and
I don't really believe you know it's up
to you if you're if you're the one being
called out and somebody says you don't
actually understand what you're talking
about
you got to do the work you know I think
that's that's perfectly fair all right
sorry about that let's see um what else
do we have here here's a remark that I'm
not quite sure what oh I think it's in
relation to one of the things I said
earlier if that totally open discussion
was anonymous it would likely be a hell
hole yeah you know the few times that
I've gone on 4chan to look at things
because people directed me to it that's
what fortune kind of looks like it's all
anonymous people all of them basically
calling each other names and making a
few good points here and there and
sharing some some interesting memes and
stuff like that a lot of you know it's
interesting this this is something that
it's been observed for now about 25
years that the anonymity of being on the
internet and not showing your actual
data enables people to say all sorts of
bad things that they they wouldn't
normally say to another person if first
started getting noticed in chat rooms
that with the issue of what we called
flaming you know and it's continued on
into social media and there's even sort
of a limited anonymity I mean a lot of
people on Twitter have handles they
don't they they don't show their face
they don't tell where they're from some
people and Facebook Facebook had to
crack down on that you remember and
people got really mad about that so I
think there's something to that that
idea that anonymous discussions can
sometimes be considerably worse because
people feel unable to like let it all
hang out all right let's see what else
we we have to do do do Nikolas Arshad
delusional individuals be kicked off
popular platforms I think of racist
gathering
4chan and end up in a bubble where
they're never challenged and have their
ideas reinforced well I mean I 4chan as
far as I understand is not going to
actually do a lot of policing unless you
know somebody is really really really
egregious right and then they find other
places to go to the times that I've been
on it it's pretty you know extreme stuff
that people are saying so it doesn't
seem like they're doing much of policing
should they be kicked off of other
platforms you know as we start moving
like into reddit which is still pretty
loosey-goosey and then getting it on to
Twitter and Facebook and YouTube and
stuff like that we're talking about the
issue of deep platforming I don't
actually have that much of a problem
with it myself but then again I'm not
somebody who tends to say a lot of
boneheaded stuff that I can't actually
find some some good justification not
and I don't mean a good justification
just from my own point of view but like
based in something for for saying and I
try not to be offensive to people as
well
because I think it's important not to
not to be offensive right you say well
that's just you know self-serving you
know what about the general principle I
mean we can look at it in a couple
different ways one is that there's Terms
of Service and if you violate the Terms
of Service then YouTube Twitter they can
kick you out I think that there have
been some individuals have been allowed
to violate the Terms of Service an awful
lot and get away with it because they're
bigger accounts Donald Trump is a great
example you know probably should have
been kicked off a long time ago of
Twitter but Twitter wanted to keep in
mind their justification was partly well
you know it's an important mode of
communication for with the general
public which is [ __ ] because he's
got a press secretary you know he can do
whatever he wants he doesn't actually
have to be on Twitter to do it he's got
full US government to do that right
Bradford says isn't the original
position the solution to all of this
with Rawls that's if you can get people
to buy into Rawls which is never going
to happen because nobody's ever you're
never gonna get like complete agreement
from from everybody I mean I find that
that bringing up John Rawls or the veil
of ignorance in the original position is
good for getting people to think about
what it's like for other people in
society and how they wouldn't like to be
in you know in a disadvantaged position
I don't think it's particularly helpful
for getting us to where we need to go in
terms of anything more robust so let's
see so Bradford brings up a good point
in Europe it is financially unviable to
fire someone for speaking their opinion
yes they have a very different viewpoint
Europe - Britain of course they have a
very different view point on what
employer labor relations ought to look
like and I hope some day we actually
move closer to that because we are kind
of the outliers among the developed
world I mean you can also say something
similar about Japan
no Australia is becoming more like the
US and Britain in that respect but yeah
we we have some really we're a real
weird outlier when it comes to a lot of
things economically and in terms of
health care and and other things as well
here in the United States all right life
brian says omar wasa made a comment on
twitter cleaning that historically riots
helped Republicans he was pummeled on
Twitter and fired from his analytics job
tell me about how he has an [ __ ] dr.
Stadler I don't know that he was I
didn't follow that one why don't you
tell me how he was since you know more
about it and there can certainly be
exceptions nobody's saying that this is
gonna be a perfect process and anybody
demanding that is probably demanding the
impossible and kind of stuck in an
ideologies
what I'd want to know is I'd want to
look at what else we know about Omer
wausau and being pummeled on Twitter you
know lots of people get pummeled on
Twitter I I've been pummeled on Twitter
before probably not to that extent but
you know people go after whatever you
have to say so that's that it fired from
his analytics job that's up to the
analytics job you know if that that's
the thing if you don't like at-will
employment maybe work so that we don't
have just at-will employment right then
we don't have to worry quite so much
about these all right
let's see what else we got here I just
skipped a little bit and I got a wrap-up
because I got a conversation very soon
about some editing work that I need to
do so I'm not going to get to
everybody's stuff let's see
scrolling up
so here's a really interesting one to
end on from moonchild when it comes to
critical thinking and I think you could
expand this to other you know constructs
as well critical thinking by the way
very equivocal term you know means a lot
of different things to a lot of
different people that's a whole
different conversation we also talk
about emotional intelligence prudence
will correct the wisdom when it comes to
these sorts of things the ego can make
us interpret information and bad faith
does it take psychological maturity to
see others in good faith yes and no it
certainly does people who are more
mature and not just psychologically but
also morally you could say they've
engaged in some moral development are
more likely to be able to engage with
others in good faith doesn't mean that
it's going to happen every time it's not
going to be perfect but we don't we
don't actually need that in order to
talk about this a lot of the people who
argue in bad faith it's usually because
in my experience there's something
flawed something broken about them and
you know that's the normal human
condition it's not to say oh they're
like defective disease or something like
that no they're they're effed up like
all of us are but they're not working at
it they're not trying to make it better
or if they are they're doing so in the
wrong way like people who get into
stoicism and you know wind up you know
not actually reading stoic text but
actually doesn't you using soundbite
stuff that they find on some listicle
and then get into the dichotomy of
control and think that stoicism is just
about withdrawing from the world right
so yeah the people who are maturing are
usually the people you know you could
say that in the Venn diagram of those
who are in good faith there's a much
bigger overlap with those who are mature
than those who are not mature and so we
really ought to take personal
development and maturation as something
important for us not just for you know
having good speech with others but for a
variety of other things you want to have
good relationships with other human
beings you want to eventually understand
you know a place in society that that's
good for you and
you can do your best stuff there you
probably need maturity I mean this is
part of why again a little bit off topic
when emotional intelligence came out
this book you know book by Daniel
Goleman one of the things that he was
saying was hey as somebody who's been a
psychologist observing you know leaders
here's one of my my takeaways it doesn't
matter what your IQ is your emotional
quotient matters way more than your IQ
for being able to like perform well at
your job because you can test really
well on you know cognitive things and
you know similes and manipulating shapes
and stuff like that but you can still be
a complete jerk because you can't read
other people and you don't know how to
respond after you've screwed things up
right that's emotional intelligence
so yeah developing as a human being
again this this notion of moving away in
free speech from just insistence on
rights and thinking about
responsibilities thinking about what
good faith looks like what what kind of
conversations you actually want to have
and being the kind of person who would
would generally have good conversations
with people I think that's really quite
important so that's a nice place to end
this on obviously I don't get to
everybody's questions and never do but
it's been a good conversation glad all
of you could join me for it and next
month I'm thinking the big topic is
going to be should we be sending all the
kids back to school or not which is an
interesting political question here in
the United States I'm going to do a
little bit of reading as well about
what's happening in all the other
countries because I want to do some
comparative analysis as well but I think
that'll be you know so it'll be August
that'll be a quite germane topic so I'll
see all of you